okay well I suppose our bed stuy I'm
just slightly bemused by this blue bar
hopefully it's no we're going to lead to
any trouble and so some of you might
have seen me talk about this week ago in
Scotland so the new thing I've got since
then is its jet lag unfortunately Anala
else so yeah it's going to be a
repetition for you guys I'm afraid this
is a joint work with the writ CEO who's
a PhD student in our groupies on my PhD
student but he works with me on this
stuff ok so we've seen lots of diagrams
I feel a bit naughty actually I had
don't think I've got a single string
diagram or network in my entire talk so
you may be feeling a bit guilty about
that but the idea is to look for
settings of these things so just as a
bit of motivation we work a lot with
these compact close categories for these
compositional things and so they sort
the canonical and possibly is finite
dimensional Hilbert spaces for pure
state quantum mechanics and then we use
the CPM construction to build it setting
for mixtape quantum mechanics is an
awful awful lot of literature on that
type of thing similarly and related to
the wit- she spoke about we can use real
vector spaces to describe natural
language semantics and playing the same
name again we can use the CPM
construction to let us get incomplete
information into play another compact
close category that's popularly used
often as counter model or as a toy model
but also as a setting for non
deterministic computation is rail which
is very familiar and we've just heard an
awful lot about these ghost bands and
correlations that do networks the
universe and everything so they're very
powerful things and spans crop up
occasionally although they're slightly
less populous so I've got this question
down the bottom which says you know
where do we find new ones and I'm not
sure that's quite the right question
because in a way just asked Brendan
because he can do all of them and so the
question maybe is is how we find the
right one inside the space of things
that brendan is constructing so that's
what wasn't
okay so if we're going to look for new
stuff we need a sort of an unusual
application area in which to start
exploring one of the things that we've
been looking at in our group is
compositional models of cognition and
one of those or mathematical aspects
that comes into play when you when in
the literature about cognition is the
importance of convexity if it's not
clear where that comes in the
simple-minded perspective is if you have
a little space in your head describing
your view of the world this is a dog and
this is a dog then stuff in between
better be a dog as well it's as simple
as that so yeah they're worried too much
about where the complexity comes from so
you might then start thinking about you
know how are we going to get some notion
of complexity involved in a compact
closed setting so initially we did this
in a sort of ad hoc manner we happen to
know a construction that was going to
get us in the right direction we start
with the finite distribution monad which
just sends a set to all the finite
probability distributions on it so
that's a good thing for forming mixtures
and we then do the usual I'm above all
construction on that and the algebra is
in there are sets that take a finite
mixture that we need to form a formal
one and produces as a mixture so it
gives us a way of talking about
convexity and its standard fact is that
these categories over I'm above all
categories / set are going to be regular
so we can form the category of relations
on those things and that's going to give
us a compact close category and
basically the way that the relations
work is if you have a whole load of
related fits then you can form the same
convex mixture of both and you're going
to get a related thing so relations
respect forming convex mixtures okay so
that sort of seemed to go well for us we
found in our top trick that solved our
problem but then the the literature
about cognition also talks about metrics
a lot here the motivations much more
straightforward if you're near to
something that you think about then you
should be similar in distance measure
sort how far apart ideas are and but how
are we going to get metrics into play
yeah well a previous trick isn't going
to pan out because the other
called categories of metrics places
aren't regular so we can't play that
game again so what we're going to do so
we're going to take a little bit of a
detour in order to get to where we want
to go and binary relation on sex can
obviously be thought of as the map from
the product into the two element and set
and then there's a fairly obvious
generalization that we've already seen
in Manisha's talk where we can
generalize our truth values to live in
an other tree cantar and we can define
identities in composition in these ways
that basically parallel the way you'd
usually usually compose relations but
substituting tenses for fans and the
joint effort usual or so everything
works in a fairly natural way and we'll
call these things few relations for lack
of a better name and and these guys form
a category in a straightforward way and
if you're quantiles commutative then
this category r lq is a compact close
category so we formed a compact close
category but we haven't quite figured
out how to get metrics involved yet okay
so we can put an order structure on the
relations in this in this category in a
completely straightforward way we just
all the things point wise using the the
quantile order and and in fact this
makes our category into a post set
enriched category and so once we've got
the category of that type effectively
it's a two category now and then we can
talk about internal more ads which you
know we seem to be going further and
further away from this metric thing
we're going to converge in the next
slide on the solution and so an internal
model is actually quite simple thing in
this setting it just means that the
identity is contained in your endo
relation and iterating around a relation
lives inside it so it and reflexive
reset reflexivity and transitivity
condition is the way to read these
things and this parallels the usual
definition of a monad in terms of a unit
and a multiplication I seem to have
missed the name off here but actually
it's simpler because the the axioms that
need to hold on haven't got any force
here because everything is thin
so the reason we took this detour is we
look at the internal Minaj in various
different of these r lq categories for
different quantiles we get some
interesting things so in the case where
it's just true false then an internal
mon at is going to be something
satisfying these axioms which basically
means that it's a pre-order so we've got
a nice structured object in some sense
and if we change our quantile to just be
the real interval from 0 to 1 and we
have a look in here this one's maybe
takes a little bit more seeing but
basically it's a sort of fuzzy pre-order
it generalizes the notion of pre-order
we saw before so more interestingly if
we take a quantile where we take the
extended positive reals we reverse the
order so that our joint is going to be
infimum and we put additive structure on
it and so this idea goes back a very
long way then we get generalized metric
spaces so if we look at what the
relatedness means it means everything is
zero distance from itself and the
transitivity condition becomes an
instance of the triangle law which is
quite a nice thing and a little tweak on
the the choice of quantile actually
gives us the ultra metric spaces instead
so that's still quite nice that we can
get our hands on these things okay so a
little summary of what we've done
basically we've just done some ad hoc
stuff in a way with and somebody in our
group you know knows the construction we
use it and we see if we can get anywhere
so and that's all worked out nicely for
these two examples and so we use this
regular category construction
particularly for algebraic things that's
what we're going to pursue and we
generalize in a minute and then we use
generalizing of truth values in order to
get the metrics in play and then we make
a quick observation that actually these
compact closed categories are hypergraph
category so we're in Brendan's territory
and and the questions that follow up
there now but can we relate these two
schemes can we do both at the same time
what have they got to do with each other
can we vary relations in other ways
relations are quite familiar things so
it might be easy to think about how we
might extend a notion of relation and
and then what happens if we vary the
parameters on these things that we vary
up
Tarla we're going to get functors
between things that whatever hysteresis
so the August place to start in
generalizing things and it's to start
with these simple ones with a different
truth value object that's their fairly
simple to deal with and then think about
how we're going to get the algebraic
structure in play so we saw a an axiom
of this form earlier which basically
said if we've got related bits then
performing an algebraic up your
operation on the bits leads to related
composites so and respecting the
compositionality of the situation if you
want to do that and we can't really say
that this here because now our truth
values aren't living in a in a lattice
they're living in a quant are so we just
follow our nose basically we replace the
hands with products in the quant are and
we replace this implication with the
order structure inside the console and
we take this as our axiom to say that
something respects the algebraic
structure so we're going to call these Q
relations algebraic so this seems to be
sort of fairly natural directions of
doing
okay and the way we've written down our
definitions actually we can interpret
all of this business in an arbitrary top
off so we've got sort of third direction
of variations we've got two so far we
had the choice of truth values and
choice of algebraic structure and
actually we can choose the sort of
background mathematics that were working
in as well and everything will work out
fine and so the first theorem we have is
if we have an arbitrary top boss an
internal commutative cantar and an
algebraic variety in there then we get a
category of these algebraic gear
relations and this category has
symmetric monoidal structure given by
products and and it's also poser
enriched by sort of obvious
generalization of the ordering that we
saw before and in fact it's an instance
of brendan's hypergraph categories so
this is kind of the spirit of what we're
looking for is is a parameterize
procedure for general a generating new
compact closed categories and where the
parameters are preferably reasonably
intuitive in terms of how you understand
them ok so we mentioned spans earlier
we're going to have a look at spans
again now so and spans a simple thing
just has a apex than a couple of feet in
a couple of morphisms that's all the
dates are involved and one of the ways
that you can think about these things
yeah email and is that we have a
constructive relations so we think of
these things are set and then we can
think of the apex as proof witnesses and
we use this informal notation we say
that little X living in the apex relates
a to be if it gets projected down onto a
and B in the feet ok so we've now got
another relation ething so we should be
able to get this into the settings
relations that we've been dealing with
so far ok so well we kind of follow the
drill that we followed before we want to
get a way of varying the truth values
that are in play and and the obvious
thing to do here is to add a sort of
characteristic morphism to these proof
witnesses that measures how strongly
they're witnessing that
related i would call such a thing
keyspan and we're going to write this
type of notation here saying think
something is related from A to B via
this proof witness and the strength of
the relation and its key so that's at
least got us as far as generalizing the
truth values ok so again we follow our
nose and the drill that we had before
and we want to add some algebraic
structure into play as well so we
basically do the same thing we did
before we require and if we have related
bits via proof values with appropriate
strength then there should be a proof
witness with strength q relating the
composites such that this Q is at least
as strong as you get by gluing together
all the truth values on the parts these
pc isn't he and ok so we know at this
point that we also need order structure
on these truth values in order to be
able to write this axiom down sir we're
in the setting of needing a partially
ordered more annoyed or something along
those lines at this point ok so we get a
second theorem now that if we have a top
off and we have a variety with it and we
have Q and internal partially ordered
commutative ma night ma noid then the
algebraic q spans former category as
before and this category is a hypergraph
category so again we're living in in
Brendan's world and in this case it's
pre-order enriched I can't show that
it's posted in rich it seems to be
pre-ordering riched with it ordering is
follow so if we have two spans this is
that data for the spans and we kind of
expect to be able to find the weaker one
within the stronger one if we want to
put it that way such that the way that
we map things in is a spam morphism for
the people that know what that means and
the truth values are stronger when we
find truth values in this or stronger
relation
okay so I've done the other like the
title of this slide but I went with it
anyway we want to be a relate this spam
construction to the rail construction so
the obvious thing to do is if I are
commutative sorry are are mono heed that
was pre ordered and comes from a quant
are then we can take all the different
witnesses saying that things are related
and then pick the best truth value so we
can kind of think of the need for a
quantile in terms of the relation
construction as acting as a sort of
optimizer picking the best way in which
things are are related so that's the
roller insert and and it turns out that
that works out nicely as well so we pick
the top boss as usual in an algebraic
variety and an internal commutative
mahanoy din our top boss then we get a
strict identity and subjective on
objects pre-ordered functor squashing
our witnesses down basically in order to
find the best one in our category of
relations so we can relate these guys
together and so you basically because
they are the same objects it's actually
going to send it to the same objects and
it means it hits everything as well so
base possibly because the other cats
really could be larger and but it's just
the way of saying it yeah it's not very
precise here
okay so just to summarize what what I've
been quickly racing through and the aim
at least is to provide a conceptually
motivated procedure for searching around
inside Brendan's large world of
hypergraph categories and finding ones
with properties that you might like and
we've ended up with four axes of
variation via which that we can pick
these things we first have to fix an
ambient mathematical universe so it toss
in which we're worth working once we've
done that we can pick an internal
quantile that describes how truth should
work we can pick an algebraic structure
there so that's the analog of this
convexity that we saw earlier and then
we can choose between proof relevance
versus prove ability in terms of whether
we end up with the span or the rail
construction and I think Sampson would
shoot me if i didn't have examples at
some point so and Sampson can put the
gun away now I hope we generate lots of
the things that we see in the literature
so we see good old rail we see this
category rail that we wanted earlier
that had the generalized metric spaces
in it also the one for the ultra metric
spaces with an appropriate choice of
algebraic structure we also get the
category of convex relations from the
other earlier example and up to
restricting to the finite dimensional
stuff we generate the category of linear
relations that's interesting to people
various people here and we also find
various directions in which we might
want to go probing for interesting
models for instance this idea of can we
combine the convexity a metric stuff
together clearly we're able to do that
now we might want to think about models
in which the meaning of the either
cognitive or linguistic stuff that we're
dealing with or whatever the application
is is varying with with context or with
user or all the time and that type of
thing and we can also exploit these the
presence of these proof witnesses in the
spam constructions in order to track not
only what holds but why it holds
effectively which would provide the
providers with some new opportunities
that we haven't had before ok and then
this mega conclusion and basically
describes everything I haven't been able
to fit into the previous 19 slides and
so
it turns out that the constructions that
we have our fun tutorial in the choice
of truth value so if you have an
appropriate homomorphism then you get a
functor between these categories and I
know what the correct word is they're
farcical e nice functors so you know
given Pavel's question earlier about how
precisely i was describing these things
they basically preserve everything in
sight so they preserve everything on the
nose as well everything is very nice
there's also the question of funk funk
to reality with respect to the algebraic
structure that seems an obvious thing to
ask and it turns out that's a more
interesting question because our truth
values are contours and so linearity
starts to come into play if you're
interpreting one algebraic structure
within another then depending on the
derived terms that you're using you may
need to copy variables or actually drop
variables and then questions of
linearity come into play but there is a
functor reality theorem more effectively
for there depending on which choices of
the amount of structure you have on your
quant or quantel you choose or
alternatively you can strip restrict the
relations that you're interested in
depending on how you want to see the
situation and in each case with all of
these constructions we get a graph
functor so by that what I mean is if you
start with a function you can take its
graph to form a relation and there's an
analog of that construction for the
constructions that I've described and
again that thinks sort of classically
nice it takes the finite product
structure on to the monoidal structure
in the categories that we're discussing
and it commutes with everything else as
well so taking graphs followed by the
various functors we describe commutes
with each other looking further ahead
it's obviously an interesting thing to
ask what the additional structure is
within these categories of relations
when do we have zero objects by products
and that type of thing and we'd like to
look at functi reality in the choice of
top pops but that's the slightly more
complicated question because as you
change the top off your kind of
compelled to move the truth values
around because they live within the top
of that needs a little bit more thought
and as Brendan mentioned earlier this
category spans really should be a
symmetric monoidal by category that is
typographic some appropriate sense now
that well that sounds loads of
fun and there's enough fun that sort of
motivation for me to go and look but a
concrete reason for being interested in
that is a well-known observation i
believe going back to at least lack that
in the category of spans if you look at
the internal monitors that we've been
interested in in the category of spans
have set then those are this exactly the
small category so that there are objects
of interest so we would we would like to
be in this by categorical setting to get
at lacks observation there and we've
been varying our truth values over
quantiles and you can actually go
further and have your truth values
valued in a monoidal category is within
thinking about what exactly that might
mean and but basically that that points
in the direction where we could unify
the span and rail constructions
depending on whether you're monoidal
category is thin or whether it's a
genuine category will connect with this
idea of whether you've got proved
ability or proves in the construction
and also a sort of small conjecture here
is if this monoidal category is
symmetric that will be the case in which
you get a hypergraph category but i
don't know whether that's true yeah it
seems an obvious thing to check and that
is everything
oh good good not sure I was gonna make a
common absence of my student can eat
cursor has a paper i'm getting go out
here my student kenny cursor has a paper
area gets symmetric monoidal by
categories of decorated coast bands
starting from brendan's type of data and
so he used mike showman's methodology
about there's a double captain Gareth
yeah I think stuff yeah this entire
vicariously you should be able to yeah
I'm aware of that as of about an hour
and 15 minutes ago when I talked to
Brenda but yeah I'm going to find out
more yeah and I also have to apologize
to you because I'm not as compulsively
honest all of my spans were obviously
equivalence classes how long shall
expand so I think I got away with it I
have a question see you too Michael
condition garden tours and the stuff any
particular model like that I mean people
argue about it right they say our
convexity is some isn't an appropriate
of all this sort of approach let's you
be much more general quite easily yeah
so do you think that gives away I mean
does the mathematics let you simply grab
some sort of maximally general model for
a cognition or something such that no
one could possibly object okay I'm not
sure we can like have an objection proof
model but the thing that we've managed
at least so far is the convexity based
one was an interesting model from that
point of view so so far we're actors or
teaser trailers and for the good stuff
and and govern was who I can't pronounce
it correctly so I avoided it in the talk
he was certainly interested in what we
were doing and is interested in
collaborating further so you had kind of
in parametric and been able to balloon
things up visit is an advantage going
forward but that the way they describe
things I would say is so pre
mathematical so part of our function
actually is to make more
is what they mean by convexity or what
they mean by distance and various other
notions that they discuss because their
mathematical but up to a point i would
say this thing about their the aren t of
the answer is this the point if the
equations of the of your algebraic
theory Alinea then everything is fine
otherwise you have to impose more
structure yeah so if the derived terms
that you're using when your interpreter
you're interpreting a binary operation
is some derived term in the second
algebra then you may be copying or
deleting things when you build that
derive term and that that axiom that
base that I had that says if you if you
have all of the related parts holding
then at least is true that combined
thing should hold that holds for the
things in the signature without the
lateral we require if you want that to
hold on all of the derived terms then
you're going to need either more
scripture on your console or you're
going to need to actually meet eyes that
your relations respect that a priori so
yeah it's linearity and these derived
terms how they're using the variables
[Applause]